[Music]
hey the flash fans i'm leanna Galera
coming at you live right now with the
one the only Jessica Parker Kennedy
there's probably another one somewhere
no the only one it matters sure we are
gonna be dishing all about the Flash's
fifth season which is coming up soon
October nights yeah very soon how crazy
is that uh it's kind of a little bit
nerve-wracking
I had an interviewer at Comic Con say to
me
are you ready for all of the scrutiny
and I thought he was gonna say like are
you ready for all the like fun stuff and
he was like you ready for all the
scrutiny and I was like yes so there's a
little bit of fear I guess that like
fans won't won't be stoked but all these
oh the most part they are poopoo on that
person for phrasing it like that like
I'm like are you ready to have some fun
or beyond in my opinion the best CW
super show that they have he kind of he
meant that but he was like that
, and all of the scrutiny but it was
yeah it was a kind of a weird question I
haven't been thinking about it
constantly since then it's fine well I'm
gonna be asking you some fun questions
we're gonna go through like a lightning
round of questions right now and for all
you fans who are watching send in your
questions in the comments below I'm
getting them on my iPad I will pass them
along to Jessica but we've got to just
jump right into it yeah you are now in
the middle of episode 7 yes how's it
been so far so fun it's the hardest work
I've ever done in my life which is great
I play a lot of supporting characters
and technically I'm a supporting
character on this as well but the first
few episodes cuz they're establishing
all my stuff my plot and all of that and
who nor is I've been there for 14 hours
a day every single day so it's it's
really nice but I'm it's really nice
because I have a job and it's awesome
and I love my job but I'm missile
retired well the flash fam has been
there this is their fifth year what
pieces of advice have the cast members
been giving you as you adjust to this
new full-time schedule in life up in
Vancouver they've given me no advice
whatsoever they welcomed me with open
arms
like I know Danielle probably give you a
Welcome Packet Danielle gives me and you
know what that girl is the most
organized woman in the world if she ever
decides to become a mama she is gonna be
the girl that in her in her bag is
everything you could ever need ever
snacks
tissues baby wipes like like emergency
kit so she's she's really good with all
the like technical stuff like remember
when like she gave me all of like the
statutory holidays right away so I could
book my flights home early that kind of
stuff and she like gets sneaky schedules
or she's like very she's like very she
says she's very good at reading upside
down when trying to look at the
schedules of like the next episodes I'm
figuring out what's going on and Link
scripts and stuff so she's a sneaky
little cat yeah so I go to her for all
my info we are starting to get in some
fan questions so keep them come in but
I've got a couple more of my own let's
just jump right into the storyline of it
all my first question is we discovered
at comic-con I had the pleasure and
honor of moderating your panel we're so
good at it you would say that it was
just such a fun time but we discovered
on that panel that it seems like there's
going to be a little bit of I don't want
to say tension between Nora and iris but
there's there's some kind of disconnect
that we're not quite sure how to put our
finger on it how would you describe it
it's tension it's more on my part I
think iris as my mom is just like trying
to bond with me but I'm just so dad dad
dad dad dad all the time not super
interested in my mom and we'll get to
the bottom of why that's happening but
yeah there's a bit of a like it's it's
so hard to play because Candace and I
like each other so much and we just have
done so many scenes not where we're just
sort of like when can I just be like
mommy I love you but yeah it's it's
actually it's it's just it's nice every
family has a awkward dynamic and and
there's you know and they're just
figuring theirs out and hopefully it all
gets sorted are you playing that tension
as if it's a little bit more like she
doesn't want to get too close or
attention as if there might be something
hidden like she's mad at her
there's always something hidden in in
these shows we're hiding everything and
it's my job to try and get this little
nuggets out what is Nora's official last
name is it
under West Allis it's West Allen with -
yes I know that because I did it wrong
at comic-con and instagrammed all about
I was like my name is Nora Allen West
and I got in big trouble for that so
West Allen's I got it yes combo though
so at least now you know now I know um
when we started getting the little
snippets and seeing you before we really
knew that you were Nora a lot of fans
picked up on different scenes with
different characters in the scene with
wells and Caitlin when you spilled the
drink on Caitlin they were picking up on
almost like a frosty tension how would
you describe that scene yeah that scene
was was interesting because I think
isn't that the one at the very end I
love that I don't know where that would
like it does a close-up on me and I'm
like smiling but then I make a serious
face yeah yeah so there I think you know
all that all that stuff is put in there
as like yes little hints and planting
little seeds for things that will grow
later so yeah I mean yeah there there
was definitely something frosty there
but I can't hand out about what it was
when did you know all of this backstory
because did you know the backstory when
you were filming those little snippets
or is it making sense now
yeah so when Todd helping asked me to
come in and pitch the part to me he did
a general idea of what the part was
gonna be and I was like totally on board
and then a couple of months ago I went
into the writers room which is very fun
to be able to go there the actual flash
writers room is very cool I don't have
all the power I have all the power
yes and I visited them all at lunch and
it was they were all like around this
table staring at me while they were all
eating and it was super awkward and Todd
basically just told me the arc of the
character ever this season but in like a
minute and a half so I just sort of I
know some of it and I don't and I
forgotten other parts of it but I trying
to just yeah don't worry I'll have it
all like sorted I'll do my homework by
the time we get to it did you actually
have to audition for this role or did
you just say look at my face I am a
clear combination anything on the doors
for months getting um they they just
called and said hey do you want to do
this part it was really cool I I mean I
still audition all the time for stuff
but this was something I didn't didn't
have to audition for so yeah it was a
yeah mr. Rapoport who's an important man
was very cool yeah it was his idea to
like get me in there so I'm very very
grateful for him I'm loving seeing these
long locks on you yeah they look great
in the little snippets before we knew
you were Nora your hair was long and
then when you introduce yourself your
hair was short yeah I don't know why
they decided to do that I think it was
like a last minute thing I think they
just wanted something funkier in future
it's more futuristic even though I don't
know why short hair us we think there's
nothing futuristic about my hair on the
show it was just a last-minute change
that they wanted to do which is great
because I don't get to have a short hair
and much stuff so it was like a very
it's a very nice change for me my
different energy yeah we're gonna start
moving on to your fan questions you guys
are sending in so many great ones dee
wants to know will we get any cute
scenes of Barry and iris sharing their
history with Nora oh there's definitely
some history sharing not necessarily all
together though they should there's some
like I spend a lot of time with my dad
on his own and a little bit of time with
my mom on her own it's kind of all you
can say it's not I'm sorry if that
wasn't very no that's good though but
okay let's be real you don't want to
spoil things yeah yeah exactly it's so
sweet because fans always ask for like
plot points yeah but you're like I mean
I do Roo nation ooh good question do you
have a shortcut for learning some of the
sci-fi lingo they used on the show I
don't know if he's referring to the
futuristic symbols but can we talk about
that oh um as of right now I just
literally copy whatever the props master
has written in the book I just do it
over and over and over because it's very
incredibly complicated symbols yeah it's
like nothing I've ever seen before I
guess it's like it's complicated the way
like Chinese would look or something
like that so I I've not done my homework
for that eventually I hope I can get a
little bit of tray down then I can write
secret notes to other people who know
that language who's just just well we
get to discover a little bit more as to
where that kind of coding comes from I
hope so okay yeah not yet but I hope so
yeah
Vaughn wants to know how is everything
how is everyone going to react to Norah
being in 2018 oh okay yeah I think it's
weird for everyone I had a dream once
that I went back in time and met my mom
and hung out with her lips before after
flash way way before like these happen
years ago and we were in in my dream my
mom had like this huge walk-in closet
and we were picking outfits together and
she didn't know I was her daughter from
the future but I think I purposefully
didn't tell her because I didn't want
her to freak out so I think if I think
what they all know and it's it's weird
for everybody there's like it like it
will she mess up the timeline like what
do we do with her like you know there's
that's a big part of it yeah well we've
seen from flashpoint that when you mess
up with like any little thing everything
can change in a timeline so I know that
without getting too technical and this
is the question that I asked like Todd
on the panel is is her coming back in
time gonna create her own flashpoint do
you know much about the mythology of
that dad I don't I I don't know what's
going to happen with that sort of stuff
but I I assume for plots sake the
crazier it gets the better it will be so
i can assume something nuts will happen
i don't i don't not exactly sure what it
is but probably in that final scene she
says I think I've made a big mistake how
long do we have to wait before we find
out what which mistakes she's referring
to pretty you'll find out pretty quick
in the premiere yeah yeah yeah yeah you
guys are killing it with all these
questions Oh Sarah sharp says please in
all caps ask Jessica Nora and Cisco's
relationship so excited for baby flash
and uncle Cisco loved this dynamic since
they met in jitters last season dude I
want to work with Carlos one-on-one so
badly so far we haven't done that I've
done a bunch of group scenes with
everybody but I am I I think it would be
like adorable I think that their their
relationship could just be so lovely and
funny and quirky and strange and sweet
and I I would love to work with him I
just think he's a great actor too and
it's amazing he's hilarious
so yeah it would be a lot of fun for me
are there any other characters besides
Barry and iris that we do get to see you
spice worth quite a bit most of my stuff
to be honest has been like we've done
group stuff I've done a lot of stuff
with Barry obviously some stuff with
Iris I have done some stuff with one
character specifically but I don't want
to say who because I think it's a really
but it's like very sweet and lovely and
I'm just gonna look down right now in my
hands grandpa can't see you can't see ya
can be anything I did love that fans
have already been joking because Grant
said at the comic-con
no one is to date Nora no he's he's
forbidden
he is forbid yeah he nor I have a love
interest or is that even is that even on
her radar right now she's trying to I
assume fix something in her own timeline
yeah I think the last thing on Nora's
mind is that I mean she's refreshing
she's a young lady I'm sure if someone
came along that caught her eyes she
would be like oh hello but but it's not
you know it's not in the forefront of
what's happening that's for sure
here's the question I want to know do
you like running no absolutely not
in the I was traumatized in junior high
school we had to do this drill where we
would either run around the school a
certain number of times or run around
the gym a certain number of times and I
remember thinking as like a 13 year old
girl that I was going to die so I've
been completely traumatized against
running I do not I don't run I hate
writing what has it been like for you
getting the speedster stance down you
know what and we've had to run I thought
it was all gonna be CGI but no there's
been takes wear it like when we have to
do slow-mo where I actually have to run
and it's do this yeah grants very
specific grant has been the lifesaver
because I watched what he said he
metaphorically holds my hand and like
shows me how to do everything I would be
nothing without him I would be a
terrible speedster a terrible superhero
so he's he's the one that shows me how
to do everything and once you actually
get that motion and you know that you're
supposed to be this cool superhero the
running is actually easier yeah so it's
actually it's it's been a little bit fun
I'll admit it's not all awful running
it's been kind of fun yeah let's talk
about your costume yeah we have the the
poster of it if we want to cut to it
what was it like for you putting
that costume seeing it for the first
time what are your thoughts you know I
was like yeah custom cool whatever and
then when I put it on it was the neatest
thing in the entire world I felt
extremely cool and I was like oh this is
why everyone's into superheroes as this
is awesome I it's just you know they
take all your measurements they measure
your toes they measure everything and
then they make something that fits you
perfectly and you feel really cool in it
so the one thing that's funny is I in my
brain I was like oh this is
indestructible but because it's a
costume that's not and I break or wreck
or rip or ruin something pretty much
every time I wear it so there's a lot of
upkeep for those costumes like stop
moving Jessica oh my gosh so much upkeep
and like how many times I've like spill
food on it's just ridiculous so bad okay
Luke says will we be told why you have
both colors of lightening and your suit
looks incredible yeah yeah you find that
yeah that's cool that's pretty neat
though is that so far in the flash we've
really just discovered that they are
metahumans because of this experiment or
because of other things but it seems
like the speedster is a genetic gene
that can be passed down so will we be
exploring that genealogy a little bit
[Music]
I'm gonna ask you another question you
can answer yes um will we see a flash
forward to what Nora's life is like in
the future uh no I mean it's not yeah
yeah yeah we haven't done anything like
that that would be so cool I hope so
well while we're on things that you
can't talk about are you gonna be in the
crossover that I don't know I was asking
that myself cuz I was like I started my
crossover I'd like to do it again I
certainly hope so but I haven't heard
anything yet mm-hmm let's talk about
your super ultra ego named XS which is
so cool you know because in the comics
xx is actually Jenny Ignatz who is Barry
Allen's granddaughter so I like that
they're kind of like shaking up the
mythology a little bit like it some
people will not like it
well yeah teach them I'm ready for the
scrutiny of course bring it out how
describe your speedster tile a speedster
style like as a excess oh my god like
miles yeah like what kind of star like
so like how would you just how she is a
hero is she like cocky
is she like still learning I she's still
learning yeah right so she's she's she's
I don't want to like give too much away
but other than to say that she is she's
in process she's baking because I make
sense you wanna but you're making when
you put that stuff on afterwards she's
baking she's like in process she's
working on it because we've seen so many
storylines of speedsters learning how to
develop their powers we watched it with
Barry we watched it with Wally and like
Jesse quick as well so well is it safe
to assume that like she knows how to use
her powers at this point she knows how
to use them I think she's incredibly
keen which you know she wants to get in
there be great you know and she's may
not necessarily be great yet so she you
know may need so just like slow slow
down a little bit she just really wants
to make her dad
really really proud that's her goal so
she you know but she's you know it says
in the trailer like my name's Nora was
son and the fastest woman alive so she's
you know she's got some stuff down for
sure yeah it's so exciting to have this
new dynamic come into the flash what has
the process been like for you just
really stepping into this role as you
get ready for everyone to really get to
know Nora a little bit scary I think I
was saying before like I just really
want the fans to like the character and
like what I chose to do with her I want
and so far everyone's been incredibly
positive about it I just want the this
season to air so that people can see it
and have their opinions about it I just
want or not to I wanted to start I just
want to like get going and also so I can
talk more about it but everyone's been
so welcoming it's been a really easy
transition for me coming into it but
yeah if like everyone's we're pretty
pretty happy so far I hope so
I am really worried though because with
her wanting her dad's approval so much
it makes me wonder if her dad is there
in her future timeline people have been
asking me that yeah so I should
how much do you know it's just a really
good question it's a great question you
got this down girl I'm trying you got
this down Tom Cavanagh said whenever
someone asks me something I'm not
allowed to answer I'm supposed to say
what do you think that is such a Tom
respond what do you think but your
question is this is exciting though
because we haven't had a full sit-down
just you and I yeah and this is gonna be
the first time money it's yeah I'm very
excited about this no so this is gonna
be sensational ooh
Denver nice question Denver wants to
know why does Nora suit have the
speedforce symbols he noticed he or she
I'm right about genders boy girl um
that's a really good question that I
can't answer but I'm that's so cool that
that you've realized that because I do
yeah is it just all over it's like down
my middle side and all the way down my
legs yeah it's very cool that's me yeah
you can't really see it unless you're
close up so I don't know how they
realized that but that's cool unless
maybe somehow it shows a close up in the
trailer that I don't remember but I
don't know yeah I mean well the flash
fans notice everything
yeah I know I know that's why that's
what that that's why you're scary but
it's also why you guys are incredible
yeah because you notice everything and
you're so dedicated and beautiful and
wonderful what is on Jessica's flash
bucket list what do you want to do oh I
really want an opportunity to have
one-on-one scenes with like every cast
member I really really do because I love
all them they're all really good actors
are all super sweet people
and I just I I'm a greedy greedy actress
so I would like to have time with every
single one of them yeah I'm really
excited to see more of the dynamic
between Nora and iris because you and
Candice are so similar just in
personality is just sitting down with
you you're both so lovely and both are
very thoughtful with your questions so
what has it been like for you just
finding that off-screen bond even though
your on-screen bond is a little bit
tense um I think in a way when you get
along with someone really well it's
easier to play attention because you
trust each other if you're not trusting
each other and you're playing tension I
think some directors would think like oh
no that's
but I want them to like not like each
other in real life so we can translate
I've never been that kind of actor so
yeah we get along like peas and carrot
so it's easy for us yeah do you know if
there could maybe be siblings that's
also a good question what do you think I
think that it would be really cool if
she had a sister named Dawn since that's
originally the comic daughter mm-hmm I
think that would be neat but right now
I'm just really excited to get to know
Nora yeah but this is this is flash who
knows she might have a doppelganger oh
my god
it literally anything could happen
litter there could be an episode where
like Nora's a cat or I don't know
anything it happened yeah yeah we are
starting to run out of time so keep
sending in a couple of fan questions as
we start to wrap so is there which
episode are you most excited for the
fans to see oh my god they all run
together for me like who Danielle is
like the perfect person to ask about
that so she's like in episode 406 blah
blah blah
they all run together for me I you know
what I love the first episode that we
film mostly because that one I can like
cuz it was the first one I can like
separate it from everything just so much
is revealed in that first episode
there's beautiful scenes between me and
Barry which are just really like really
lovely and Nora still has that like
quirky silly energy that I love to play
so much so for now that's my my favorite
app well and the querque energy is very
berry in the pilot yeah which it's funny
I really was it wasn't my intention I
really felt like the writing did that
and then everyone was like oh my god
you're just like Barry and I was like
very relieved so ya know well as we wrap
it up right here I see that there's one
more fan coming in um but what would you
like to say to the flash fans before you
run off on this journey together more
than anything honestly I actually just
right here specifically wanted to talk
to the flash fans not just the flash
fans but like also everyone who's this
is I am Casey who's going through every
with Florence who's coming in it's so
incredibly scary and I'm thinking of you
and something you love and positive
vibes and I just um ya know that you're
just like constantly I'm on my mind
right now and I hope that everything I
hope that everything's okay that was so
sweet
yeah it's scary it's terrifying it's a
very terrifying situation right now so
keeping everyone and uh who's in the
path of Hurricane Florence in our
thoughts right now Jessica thank you so
much for sitting down with me and
letting me pester you with as many flash
questions as I could you are never a
posture it is such a joy I will I'm the
pastor because I can never answer them
so they will be more as as we start to
see more and we're gonna come up and
visit you on set we're gonna have so
much fun we'll be able to share even
more with the flash fans out there we've
got a couple little tricks up our
sleeves that are coming up for
Flashdance s is great so for all of you
guys please be sure that you tune into
the Flash's season five premiere because
it's coming our way Tuesday October 9th
on the CW you can see this lovely lady
suit up keep it locked to EG online for
more flash news and until next time see
you later guys thank you bye guys
[Music]